hello YouTube chest lowers in my friends
this is grunge in here and welcome to
the fourth part of dirty chest tricks to
win fast in this lecture I'm going to
show you our interesting line against
the Carrigan defense if you don't have
any system against the karaoke and
defense then I certainly insist you to
look at this line in depth because it
contains lots of tricks and traps
now before we see this tricks is a one
point I like to mention is in this video
I'm not covering the whole theory I'm
just showing you the tricks exist in
this line so if you have a patient like
what happens if black does this move
then I strongly recommend you that look
at the theory section of this line so
considering all this let's get started
after E for the caro-kann defense start
with the moves c6 and the normal move
over here for the white is to play the
d4 but I'm not recommending that move
instruct that I'm recommending the move
Knight to c3 and after the usual
response of the carry on defense which
is the D for now white will play the
move Knight to f3 so you can see I have
highlighted by the arrows over here
mainly black has three good choices by
the way the main line is Knight to f6
which we are not going to see in this
lecture because there's a big
theoretical line without any tricks so
you have to study that but we are
certainly looking some nice tricks exist
in this moves and those moves you are
going to meet frequently at the club
level
so the first move I want to see is the
very nation looking the move d4 so
attacking the knight and here I should
review the knight to the e2 and attack
the D pawn now the natural response over
here for the black is to play c5 so
protecting that pawn and now once again
white will renew the threat of capturing
the d4 while the MU c3 now if d capture
c3 then Knight capture c3 and white
portion is verified but I bet that many
of your opponent will think oh I can
grab more space and hit that night with
the MU d3 what's wrong in that the
nature responses when white plays the
move Knight to f4 which has a double hit
to the d3 that can play the move c4 and
it looks like black has a very
impressive pawn structure early in the
game well see yourself because we have
the foss trick on the table which is
Queen to b4 check now no matter how
black response is for example whether
black plays Knight to c6 or Bishop to d7
white can capture the c4 pawn and now
the amazing thing is once the c4 pawn
drop there is no way black can defend
the d3 phone so for example the usual
line continues with the e6 and after
Bishop takes d3 just in the opening
width under the ten moves why it is in
the winning position so please watch out
for this wonderful trick
now most likely when you reach this
position your opponent is going to
capture the epon and after white
recapture he will churn out this nature
looking move that is Bishop to f5 in
fact this is one of the most theoretical
move recommended in the campaign books
but here it's a big big mistake because
first of all white can play the move
Knight to g3 attacking the bishop and
after Bishop goes back to g6 now white
can play the move at four so you can see
H Phi is coming and it will trap the
bishop so again the MU recommended from
the black perspective is the moon at six
the moon at six provides Bishop too high
to the h7 square so after Knight to e5
Bishop will drop back to the h7 and here
comes our second amazing trick that is
Queen to h5 so you can see right now
white is threatening to checkmate black
on f7 so black response is pretty much
forced black has to play the move g6 so
it's attacking the Queen but the
downside is this Bishop is trapped and
now White has the another short which is
Bishop to c4
and especially if you're playing very
quick games this is most likely happen
that without a much thinking black
straight away capture the Queen which is
G cross at five afterwards
white will simply checkmate plaquing so
that is one cheap trick exist don't
expect every time it will happen but
sometimes you will get this most of your
opponent will spot this and they will
like you to play the move a six so
stopping the made threat and now white
we play the move Queen to e2 and you
might thought that the trick is over but
no still the biggest trick is yet to
come because at this position believe it
or not but somehow black Queen has to
protect the f7 and no other black piece
can move let me show you what I mean
imagine that black plays a random moves
such as Knight to f6 well here comes the
Big Shot because now white can stun the
black with the move Knight takes f7 and
here black has to give up the rope and
move the Queen
because if black foolishly captured this
Knight
then after Queen takes c6 Jack King to
g7 and Queen to f7 leads to checkmate
instead of Knight to f6 if your opponent
plays Bishop to e7 then more or less the
same story because we are going to
capture the f7 again hitting the two
pieces and after King recapture the
take the e6 with a check and now white
will play quiet but a very dangerous mu
that is Knight to e4 I got this position
in one of my game and hear my opponent
responded with the move Queen to d7 so
he's desperate to get rid of my queen
but after just one move Queen ePHI and
my opponent realized that he lost a
piece there is no way I can stop white
to capture that rope because if black
plays Knight to f6 then white can simply
capture this Nile because that bishop is
pin and on the top we have a folk now at
this position instead of at six you
might think after h5 why doesn't have
any tricks left well to give you a
surprise let me show you one of my game
which will tell you the story so here I
responded with the move Knight to e4
attacking the bishop bishop cannot drop
backs because the h5 pawn is hanging so
my opponent responded with an oyster
looking move that is Queen to d6
protecting that Bishop and here I
capture that Bishop and after black
recapture with the Queen
now I played the move Bishop to e2 so
you can see I am pressurizing the h5
fawn and this is one of the big drawback
of this line
here black has the only mood to protect
that pawn that is the Knight to f6
afterwards I continue with the
normal-looking move which is d4 and here
black follow the theory with Knight B to
d7 and after Bishop to g5 he played the
mu e six which looks very natural
because it's freeing up the bishop but
after White's next move probably black
will recreate his move and this is most
likely happen in your game as well
because I played the move Bishop to d3
and more or less Queen doesn't have any
square so my opponent has to just give
up the night and in a way White has a
winning position now after Bishop to a5
and when white plays Knight to g3
another move black and fries the move
Bishop to g4 against this white can
trick black with this move which is
Bishop to c4 because as for the normal
theoretical move that is Knight to f6
can be leads to a disaster after Bishop
cross f7 check King takes and Knight to
e5 check so [ __ ] Bishop and the king
and after King goes somewhere for
example let's say eat then not only
white will regain the piece but white is
a clear point up where black King lost
to castle right
in the second line after D Crossy for a
night cross e for that can try this
second move which is Knight to d7 well
against this if you are very desperate
and you know that your opponent is
weaker then you can try out this another
cheap trick that is Queen to e2 and
after the normal looking who Knight to
f6 can leads to immediate disaster
because y can play the Moon Knight to d6
and this is a checkmate don't laugh
this can be happen but don't expect too
many of them because most of your
parents for this so instead of Queen to
e2 I recommend here over here is you
play the move Bishop to c4 and this has
amazing venom whenever I use this
position probably 50 to 60% of my
opponent fall into this trick so please
watch out this so after the ship to see
for the normal looking move over here is
Knight to f6 because if now white
capture that 9 then black can always
regain the night with Don of the night
but here why it has a fantastic move
which is Knight to g5
so heating the f7 so the only response
left is e six and now white will play
the move Queen tweet now as for the
theoretical manual the only good move
over here is Knight to d5 but I will
give you guarantee most of your opponent
will not find this and instead of that
they'll go for this tracking looking
move that is Knight to b6 and the funny
thing is if you turn on the engines or
any computers even they are recommending
this move but this cannot be good for
black because after White's next move
that is Knight to e5 how the hell black
is going to stop Knight takes f7 the
answer is cannot the most accurate reply
over here is Knight captures Bishop and
Queen captures Bishop and after Queen to
defy white will simply exchange the
Queen and then take the free pawn and no
matter how black wriggles over here
those Knights can easily come out so for
example at this point black has to play
the move rook to g8 and then white will
simply cancel on the King side and you
might thought that at six will NAB the
night but no y can play the move rook to
even check and after Bishop to e7 Knight
to d6 check because that Bishop is spin
and let's say King goes to the t7 then
white can simply capture the bishop if
now black captured the g9 then white
will capture the bishop so more or less
black has to capture the C night
afterwards this night will come back and
after all the transaction what is a
clear pawn up
now at this point instead of night to be
six if you open and play the moves such
as Bishop to e7 then this is another big
trick because now white can again go for
our old friend that is Knight takes
Epsilon I think you get a hang of this
night to have seven the call it leads to
a great victory for white again black
cannot capture the night because if
black capture denied then Queen takes c6
black cannot go either f8 or e so Queen
has to come out afterwards it's a mating
for so what we continue with the King to
f7 chat and if King goes to that 6 then
d4 and the only reply left is G Phi
afterwards I can simply capture this
pawn and it's a checkmate and instead of
king to at six
if King goes to their file and so more
funny because now we are going to play
Bishop to e6 Shaq and King has again the
only space lab that is f4 afterwards
white will play the move d3 and this is
also a judgment
last but not least if your opponent is
very aggressive he might try out this
move it is Bishop to g4
but there are some nasty clicks exist in
this line as well here white will
continue with the move Harry black will
continue with the move Bishop to h4
there's no point of giving up the bishop
pair just for nothing and now white will
take the D pawn and after black
recapture it's time for the bishop check
now black cannot block this check with
the Knight to d7 because the d4 pawn
drops so more or less knight c6 is force
afterwards white will continue with the
move g4 attacking the bishop and after
Bishop to g6 white will play the move h4
so you can see now H Far East threatened
so that is a one kind of nuisance for
the black so the most nature looking
response over here is the move at six
but now our dirty chest trick start with
the move Knight to e4 we are
pressurizing more on c6 square which
black has to defend with the move look
to c8 afterwards we are going to play
the move Queen to f3 so it's a double
attack to the d5 pawn and when black
defend this pawn with the movie six now
we have the very amazing trick that is
the
that's fine Peck will find his horror
that he cannot move the bishop because
if the bush up moves anywhere then Queen
takes f7 leads to the checkmate
so I hope you enjoy this wonderful
tricks please feel free to comment on my
video and I'll meet you soon bye